[Music]
if he were to release that memo he would
not only be endangering our country but
he would also be violating the rules of
the Congress of the United States the
release of this memo is really
reminiscent of the darkest days of the
McCarthy era there is ZERO proof or even
evidence that there is a political bias
in the FBI but if you say it long enough
and is and and often enough there will
be people who have doubts about it and
it's a profoundly unpatriotic thing to
do you're not patriotic if you want your
questions answered Democrats are lashing
out that's not even strong enough
something profound is happening here but
they're very upset by the release of the
FBI memo House leader Minority Leader
Nancy Pelosi said president Trump quote
just sent his friend Putin a bouquet
many have said similar intemperate
things including Democratic congressman
Eric swallow of California he joins us
tonight so congressman many Democrats
including Democratic leaders Pelosi and
shift to name two said before this was
released that its release would
jeopardize American national security
that turned out to be a lie provably
because there's nothing in this that was
classified in fact there's no obvious
reason was classified in the first place
so why would they tell us that when they
knew it wasn't true good evening Tucker
you should be concerned about this too
it does reveal sources you should read
the memo just because he knew the
sources beforehand because they were
reported on doesn't mean we acknowledge
them in ongoing investigation so please
know more about how please be precise
about how it jeopardizes our national
security because a lot of us are
concerned about doing that and I would
never want to play any role in doing
that and that's why it's such a serious
charge and that's why we do make a role
in doing that right now but tell me how
you're playing a role because we don't
acknowledge sources in ongoing
investment source are you talking about
and how does that impair our country
well that the met the memo goes into
Papadopoulos and Paige and others that
you only knew about because they were
reported on not because I knew about
because Pappas was indicted larger than
memo came out so just explain to me how
you just accused me of endangering
American national security and I think
it's fair to ask you to be very precise
and explaining how I'm doing that so
please do but
Archer danger that I'm not gonna let you
go you just got to you got your choices
you can either apologize and take it
back or you can explain it I think it's
fair to ask you when you said I was no
how how does that jeopardize our
country's security because we don't
reveal the sources and ongoing
investigations
Tucker right now and every let me finish
let me finish Tucker and every police
station in America the police are
interviewing a suspect and you're
suggesting that we should give the
suspect the evidence before we ask them
the questions in this country but wait
the White House evidence in the Russia
investigations of me is an American
citizen who got a chance to read this
much-talked-about memo today and I
listened to people like you tell me and
now explicitly tell me that I'm hurting
our country by reading it and I want to
know how we're also hurting our country
by not acknowledging the rule of law has
been run over there using the police to
attack one okay one serious crime at a
time so which is why you're not
answering my question but I gave you a
chance or not making no I have literally
no idea the answer that's the problem
then why do you change the answer we
know from this the Carter page four
times was described by the Department of
Justice by the FBI as an agent of a
foreign power Russia four times so the
question anyway 13 as well he was not
accused of that in 2013 he was something
that has not been revealed before but I
usually something you should have read
which was his testimony to our committee
where he acknowledged he was personai in
the indictment in 2013 where he was
suspected of being a Russian foreign
agent oh but I don't think he was
accused of it let me ask you this though
do you think was suspect you think okay
do you think since the DOJ accused him
of that before a FISA Court do you
believe it is he a foreign agent simple
question what do you think he was under
suspicion it's an ongoing investigation
that's not closed that's the problem
Tucker look
you want you think ease of four and
comment on it it's open it's still an
open investigation I think your opinion
if you're going to impune the man's
character as you relentlessly have
suggesting that he's betraying his
country committing treason I think it's
fair to ask you man to man an honest
question a straightforward woman no
innuendo do you think he's betraying his
country I think you're not allowing the
FBI to answer that question with what
you and others are doing to undermine
you're kidding I also be answered
I sit here an open willing repository
for all information including your memo
including the documents that supported
this memo including this a you supporter
member community I want to be clear of
course I do
are you support absolutely okay I said
we should talk about a question that
gets to the true invite me about what I
don't saw in Washington what I don't
support is making reckless allegations
about other Americans that you cannot
support as when you said I was harming
our country's national security and as
when you suggested Carter page was
betraying this nation and I want to know
you're peddling a narrative that
narrative ask you a question you just
said on my air on my show your
imperiling our national security I said
oh really congressman how am i doing
that
am I going to be arrested for that
because I don't know it seems like the
thing a man could be arrested for yeah
these are important times in our history
either you have so those that are
undermining the independence of the
Department of Justice and the rule of
law or you're standing firm and saying
this is wrong Tucker I wish you're on my
side because I think you know better I'm
not sure what the hell you're talking
about
I only wish I think you don't like what
you're talking about but more profoundly
I don't understand it and when you
accuse someone is were arrested
why don't you game it out for me tell me
one thing that I have said that you
think makes all Americans including my
children less safe you continue to
support the idea that we should give
suspects in criminal cases the evidence
against them before we ask them any
questions I also believe that I do think
we should keep it down as the
Constitution requires as you know call
me a liberal when if I said that I think
that we should give evidence
to an I'm sure that means i by the way i
think people charged in a in a criminal
case have the right to the evidence
against them do they do you think wait
are you being questioned Tucker
yeah Tucker not when they're being
questioned not when they're under
suspicion do you think it's a problem
with the Russian investigation well do
you think it's a problem that they were
sent evidence in the Russian
investigation when they are subjects of
the investigation don't see a conflict
there what in the what Rafa maybe I
would Dominus in the case of today's
memo what specifically have I espoused
that empowers threats to our country
you're peddling the narrative that the
Trump administration is putting out
which also is the Putin narrative
because they're retweeting this with
their Russian BOTS this same type of
wikileaks you and do you pursue the same
size WikiLeaks and Putin you should take
a step back and wonder whose bidding are
you really doing I don't even know what
to say I don't want to explode on TV so
I'm just gonna end the segment now what
the record plays actually working for a
hostile foreign government